- I finally got my on MTV.
Some people might thing that's
selling out or whatever,
but I don't really give a.
That's great to me,
I'm proud of myself.
We've always been a outcast and
and it's kind of cool 'cause it's
what's going to make
us great in the future.
I don't know what the
word potential means,
'cause potential,
that's a gap.
You stop.
That's a wall.
I wanted my own network.
I wanted to do something cool
and it's always about
just me doing something
that I think is awesome.
- He's an American rapper,
record producer,
and music video director.
He rose to prominence as the leader
and co-founder of the alternative
hip-hop collective Odd Future.
He has his own clothing
company called Golf Wang
and his own streaming
company called Golf Media.
He's Tyler, The Creator
and here's my take on his
top 10 rules for success.
Rule number eight is my personal favorite,
and make sure to stick around
all the way to the end for
some special bonus clips.
Also as he's talking,
if he says something that
really resonates with you,
please leave it in the comments below
and put quotes around it
so other people can be inspired as well.
Enjoy!
(triumphant music)
- Greatness has a different
definition to different people.
Greatness to me is when
I land that fakie halfcab heel
on my skateboard or some.
Greatness is the song
I recorded last week.
Somebody might not find that great
but it's great to me,
and that's all that matters,
what the I think in my head.
As long as I like it
that's all that matters.
Greatness to me is finally
getting my video on MTV.
It's on there now and I'm happy.
I finally got my on MTV.
Some people might think that's
selling out or whatever,
but I don't really give a.
That's great to me.
I'm proud of myself.
I been wanting that since
I was seven years old,
and I finally got that.
Hard work pays the off.
I was always the class clown
even though I was kind of weird and.
And it's kind of like
I've always been an outcast
'cause they never with me.
I know we're the outcasts
I mean if you listen to the music.
Or just us in general,
you made me a person.
I'm just serious now,
but I'm always jumping around.
I'm surprised I sat down still this long.
We've always been a outcast and
and it's kind of cool
'cause this is what's
going to make us great in the future.
At the end of the day,
throughout all the jokes
and bull or whatever,
just always be yourself.
That's one thing that I'm like,
just do what the you like.
That's what I try to tell people,
just to do what the they want
impressing others.
That's why at the end of the day,
I'm always going to make
the music I want to make.
Like people get so caught up in
making their first album
Bastard was pretty successful,
but people are like,
oh I want to make something like that
but I can't.
It's progression, I'm in
a whole different mindset.
I'm having a interview right now.
I wasn't having that shit a year ago,
so I'm going to make the
music that I want to make now
that sounds cool to me.
Who knows?
I might end up doing coke
or being a drug addict two years from now
or making some off the wall music.
At the end of the day,
I'm going to like it,
and I think that's one of the main reasons
why people is we do what we want.
- When you think about catalog,
when you going to do
Cherry Bomb the album,
are you thinking now like,
man I got so much out there that
not that you're in
competition with yourself,
but is there expectation,
is there pressure,
and what's the process
of going into an album?
- I just try to be better than most.
I just try to make the music.
It's like songs that I'm like,
damn I will never make
a song better than that.
I will never make a song
better than Stevie Wonder's,
Where Were You When I Need You?
So I always use that like,
God dang I have to make
something good like that.
And that's what pushes me
and the fact that in my own head
I think I will never make something
as good as the songs that I love,
will always, and that's
that thing that I said,
I can never grasp it so
I always push myself.
That's why I don't know what
the word potential means.
'Cause potential,
that's a gap.
You stop.
That's a wall.
I don't know what that means
so I always push myself harder
and whether people like it or not,
at least for me,
I'm trying things and trying
to be better, you know?
Well when I was younger,
about let's say 16, 17, 18, 19.
I was more creating worlds and characters
and I would read a lot just
'cause me liking to learn.
I would read about certain people
and then just try to get in their head
and see how they would write a song.
And then now,
I kind of just write about my life.
Like I have a song called Hair Blows
on the new album that's just talking about
I like when this girl
hair blows in the car.
And I wrote that because I was
with a female friend of mine
and we were in my car
and she was hanging out the sunroof
and her hair was blowing
and I felt like the man,
and I wrote a song about it.
And I think a lot of
artists kind of mess up
because you don't know much about them
after a certain point in time.
So I realized none of my music will
sound the same if I just write songs
actually about my life 'cause every
two years you should not be
in the same place you were.
- But it does take some courage though
to be still transparent
about your own life.
- Well a lot of people aren't honest
'cause their not
comfortable with themselves.
So that's why you have a bunch of songs
about the same things on the radio
because one, it's comforting
to a simple listener
and two, people just aren't
comfortable with themselves.
They're not.
If I was like, hey I'm depressed,
you'd be like, wow.
But 'cause a lot of people
won't be able to do that
or tell you what they like
and stand for it and
why they won't like it,
and that goes again with a lot
of people being close-minded.
- Are you going to paid up
front from this from Lloyd,
is Lloyd going to cut you a check?
- Am I getting paid up front for this?
- You didn't get your check?
- I don't know,
but it's not about money for me.
It's not.
I wanted my own network.
I wanted to do something cool,
and it's always about just me doing
something that I think is awesome.
The money will come,
I'm not worried about that.
That'll come when the universe
decides for it to come.
We live in a society where a
lot of people are followers
and they can't make their set opinions.
Like I have friends going
to college for stuff
that their parents want them to go for,
and they're not even happy or anything,
but they're just trying to please them
and in the long run,
I mean what's going to be there?
Your parents die
and you're just stuck there
paying debt for something that
you didn't even want to
learn in the first place,
so I just try to tell people
to just think for themselves
and they'll be way
happier in the long run.
- Here's Tyler.
I'm DJ Skee.
And that was the carnival.
- The carnival was tight.
- How did it feel,
this was the fourth one?
- Mhmm.
- Did you think it would grow
to be something this massive?
- No, we was going to cancel it this year
but we didn't.
We was literally like (bleep) it
and then we did it and
then a lot of people came.
- Why were you going to cancel it?
- I don't know,
we couldn't find anyone to perform.
It was just such like a,
'cause we're specific on how we want it,
who we wanted there,
things like that
and we couldn't come up
with the perfect thing.
And it was just a depressing time
and we was about to say
(bleep) it until we was like,
(bleep) it, what are doing?
Like, where's our spirit?
And we just.
We ran it back.
This is our biggest.
We dummy doubled-up since last year.
It's crazy.
- Tyler for you,
you've got a deal on Cartoon Network,
that's Time Warner.
You've got a deal with Sony,
you've used this apparatus
even though you're only 23.
You've used this existing
system to build up your profile.
Do you think you could start literally
without any of this support
system and create yourself?
- Yeah, of course.
'Cause that's how I started.
The way that I got famous
was me going on Tumblr
and creating my own website
and just putting things out like that
with the strategic.
It had a strategy to it,
but putting out music for free
and that's how it got known
and then next thing I know,
Sony's like, hey, we'll
give you a bunch of
money to do X and O
and we just eat a little bit.
And I've used them to my advantage
in the same way that I've used
other things to my advantage.
- They didn't make you.
- No not at all.
So I know how to do this
without those platforms.
The fun thing about this is.
we, in our squad,
we're not afraid to fail.
Like we're not scared
of failing or whatever.
So we're learning as we go.
So maybe this doesn't work out,
but it'll be a learning experience
and that'll help other people
look at the mistakes we made
and figure out what they're trying to do.
I don't know, I don't give
a about trying to make.
What I think people will like.
I think because it doesn't
sound like one full album,
from top to bottom,
people disregard it.
Because it's all over the place,
people think it's messy or chaotic,
but I think it's beautiful chaos
and it's perfect
and it's my favorite album to date
regardless of what anyone says.
And I can understand why
people don't like it,
it's different
and sometimes different doesn't
equal good to some people
but I love it.
And that's great.
That's all that matters in the end.
If you make something you 100% love,
and everyone loves it,
that's a win-win.
That's great.
If you have something that you really love
and everyone hates it,
at least you love it
and you just move on.
- You've been successful
for a few years now,
have you ever had a regular job?
- I worked at Starbucks and FedEx,
and oh my God.
(laughs)
Horrible.
- [Jimmy] Oh, was it really bad?
- Starbucks was cool 'cause I
stole cheese danishes everyday.
FedEx was so depressing,
it was just.
The spirit there was just older dudes
just pushing boxes but okay with it.
And it scared the living hell out of me
so I quit after a week and four days.
- How long did you work at Starbucks?
- Two and a half years
and this lady named Cindy,
she was a new manager,
she hated on me and she fired me
and I hope she's watching
'cause I still hate her.
(laughs)
(audience applauds)
I hate you, Cindy!
I hate you so much.
I hate you Cindy.
(laughs)
- Is Cindy aware of your success?
- I hope.
Her firing me was the
greatest moment of my life.
- [Jimmy] Was it really?
- My chains was free!
- Wow how did she do it,
she sit you down and say it's time to go?
- No, one of the shift managers
warned me like 10 minutes
before she fired me.
So I had nine minutes to call my mom
asking her what I should do.
- Oh.
- Yeah, it was tight.
Somebody was like,
Yo, you're getting fired
in nine minutes boy.
- And what did your mom tell you to do?
- First she was going to sue Starbucks.
(laughs)
Then we figured out
they did nothing wrong.
(laughs)
- That's no reason not to sue.
- So okay that was nine minutes,
so I had about four minutes
left to figure out what to do
so I manned up and said alright,
I'll get fired,
and I ate three cheese danishes.
(laughs)
- Thank you guys so much for watching.
I made this video because
365 Days asked me to.
So if there's a famous entrepreneur
that you want me to profile next,
leave it in the comments below
and I'll see what I can do.
I'd also love to know
which of the top 10 rules
had the biggest impact on you and why?
What are you going to change in your
business or life after
watching this video?
Leave it in the comments,
I'm going to join in the discussion.
Finally I wanted to give a
quick shout-out to BestYouPro,
thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my book
and tweeting that awesome picture.
I hope you enjoy the book,
enjoy reading it,
and have a great time with it.
So thank you guys again for watching.
I believe in you.
I hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your own word is.
Much love, I'll see you soon.
- Music's all feeling,
and I think a lot of
people are forgetting that.
A lot of people,
especially in rap,
it's either like.
For the most part people are like,
Where's the deep lyrics?
What does he mean?
I wanted any substance.
But a lot of things are feeling.
That's why even though
I'm not a fan of a lot of
the popular trap music or whatever,
it's all feeling.
It feels good.
So what they sayin',
it's just a good feeling.
And at least on my album,
every song is like a photo for me.
Every song is like a moment.
It's a mood.
Blow My Load is two
minutes of just eatin'.
That's what it sounds like.
That's the score for that.
Every song for me is a score
for moments in my life.
- [Interviewer] And it's visual to you.
- Yeah, so Two Seater,
that's what it sounds like driving
from Hollywood to where I live
during the sunset in L.A.
That's actually my car noise
I recorded on my phone.
That's what it.
Everything I'm talking about on that
song is real life.
Doing 100 on the street.
But it's okay 'cause my
car is going to stop,
my breaks are good.
Cherry Bomb, the song,
the crazy one,
that's what it sounds
like when I'm in mosh pits
and it sounds like.
Death camp sounds like that.
Okaga, the last song,
sounds like that moment when you're
with someone that you really like,
and time doesn't matter
and you're just enjoying company
and you just like,
We should just leave this place and.
Smuckers sounds like God,
like I'm the man.
Keep Da O's sounds like this.
This is Keep Da O's.
This is that right there.
This right here but
skating down the street,
that's what Keep Da O's sounds like.
And my verse on there is
about knowing I can lose all of this
and I need to make sure I'm focused and.
That's always in the back of my mind.
Young sounds like being
in a sunflower field.
That's why it's in the video.
- It does.
- Brown Stains with Q sounds like a sherm.
That's what PCP sounds like,
when the nigga flips.
Like that's why it's just chillin' and
and then out of no where it's boom boom.
That's the feeling of it
and a lot of people are forgetting
what feeling is and only
want the deep lyrics
or some bull and that.
It's feeling.
Every song I make is a movie.
Some people just think I'm
talkin' 'about rape all the time,
but they don't really
listen that every song.
Like the song, Blow.
I was just sayin' in another interview,
that's from the mind of Ted Bundy.
Like the way he got
females with his charm,
and the smooth way that he got it.
He was was so slick with it and.
I wrote that song from his mind state
and if you listen,
every song that I make is exactly
like a movie.
So hopefully when you
go home and you listen
to Bastard or anything,
just envision it as a movie
and a storyline in your head
and you'll get how cool it is,
and it's not just me talking about random
even though it is just
me talking about random.
- [Interviewer] A few things
that have inspired you lately,
I know you guys don't have just one genre,
one form of inspiration.
- To be better than everyone.
'Cause I hate everyone.
And I want to be better than them
and I want them to know that.
So I'm coming for Kanye West's head
'cause he's my competition.